welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of a falcon
in the winter soldier episode 5
truth in which julia louie dreyfus
leaves john walker more dumbstruck than
a shield to the face
i'm going to explain your big questions
and break down all the subtle details
that you might have missed in this
episode so we open on john walker mid
sprint just like how captain america the
winter soldier opens for sam wilson and
steve rogers in the middle of their runs
except this cap is running from his
problems not
interested in making friends but listen
to the music
[Music]
composer henry jackman recalls his music
from captain america civil war
[Music]
you also hear this light motif later
this whole fight mirrors that two-on-one
fight that ended that film
in which bucky teams up to take down a
rival who is filled with rage over
a dead loved one now sam's focus goes to
the blood still on the shield
john yeah notice that vibranium hums
a sound effect they often do with the
shield that indicate it's kind of weird
mystical qualities but here it's boosted
up as if
steve's spirit is dismayed at these
stains now bucky tries to calm jon
don't go down that road believe me it
doesn't end well
i'm not like you yeah notice how bucky
just takes this
in biting his tongue letting the other
two talk for a bit and he only speaks up
once more
in the last line spoken right before
punches are thrown you don't want to do
this
yeah we do but we gotta break down this
fight move by move
because everything is amazing in it
early on bucky grapples with walker and
goes for his gun
smartly disarming him as soon as
possible and he knocks that gun loose
but in response walker in slow motion
raises the shield to bring it down on
bucky's head
just like he did to nico so we're
freaking out but sam jumps in to save
bucky
and that scary moment happens again at
the end of the battle when walker brings
that shield down on sam this time
until bucky returns the favor i love the
way sam uses his wings in this fight
first using one to slap that shield out
of walker's left hand before he catches
it with his right and then later sam
backspins on his wings to tripwalker
and when walker throws the shield at
bucky knocks him off his feet bucky
catches the shield
and briefly wields it if you think about
it every time on the series when john
walker flings something at bucky
bucky always catches it walker throws
bucky smashes his vibranium arm causing
it to glitch briefly though it appears
to recover shortly after
sam tries to tether this shield similar
to how peter parker webbed the shield
and civil war out of cap's hands but it
does work walker pinsum rips off his
wings and they restrain walker to try to
pull the shield off his arm
similar to the avengers dog piling on
thanos to remove the infinity gauntlet
until inevitably
using the force of sam's jet pack they
freaking break his arm
ugh if you think about it though steve
rogers arm was also broken as he bought
thanos and in-game remember there was
that close-up where he tightened the
shield strap as a tourniquet
so in that way steve fused the shield
with himself to make himself whole
whereas walker breaks himself over his
attachment to that shield i mean
throughout the mcu one of the best
things about this shield is the way it's
been used in collabs and here is another
collab for those books
now bucky drops the shield for sam
another mirror of the way cap dropped
the shield for tony in civil war and as
he does this he is
bathed in these beams of sunlight almost
getting steve's blessing to return his
spiritual symbol to its rightful place
and right on that drop a little glimmer
of light reflects off the shield
and as bucky walks off listen again to
the music
[Music]
yeah the composer is bringing back the
end of the line music that he composed
for captain america winter soldier that
was the moment when cap dropped the
shield to show
his friendship to bucky i'm not gonna
fight you
[Music]
you're my friend later on toria sells
bucky
hey you got your uh you got your sleeve
back he's calling back bucky tearing off
his sleeve before that dumb jump out of
the plane in episode two
and sam tells stories to take these
broken wings
wait yo you forgot the wings cable
yes juaquin torres does become a version
of the falcon in the comics when sam
becomes captain america
so we could be looking at the origin for
new falcon
i mean sam's line here does feel a bit
like tony's moment with that pre-recast
roadie in iron man
next time baby more like next time
walker goes on trial before a council
you can see the flags for the us army
u.s navy air force coast guard so i
assume this is some combination of the
joint chiefs maybe with the chairman of
the senate armed forces committee
because he's a senator they're military
people
maybe this is a government body
representing the us delegation to the
grc
look it's post blip who knows how
government works then walker goes
kavanaugh
i lived my life by your mandates i
dedicated
my life to your mandate and then a very
cold
you built me yeah through walker's rage
we are given a clearer reference point
for
isaiah bradley who was another super
soldier who's just following orders but
in his case
he was not allowed to walk free so what
does john walker have to complain about
then walker is approached by cameo
alerts a little cameo
seinfeld and veep star julia louie
dreyfus
contessa valentina allegra to fountain
so you can just call me val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head yes contessa valentina allegra
de fontaine
is a longtime shield agent in the marvel
comics often associated with nick fury
she goes by agent 14
and at another point madame hydra when
she joins hydra
but that was really a short-lived
mission when she was actually part of
the leviathan and she was betraying
hydra undermining them
folks defontaine is a lesser known
figure and a lot of folks right now are
jumping on her being madame hydra
confirmed but that arc was really just a
small part of her run
like she plays a big role in secret
invasion replaced by a skrull who really
kicks off nick fury's initial suspicions
she works on a femme force team with
sharon carter you could jump to the
conclusion that she
is the power broker the show has been
hinting at though i think it would be a
bit weird to introduce
this big cameo right now but then wait
to
doubly confirm her as the power broker a
character who is referred to with male
pronouns
i mean she may just represent whatever
faction of hydra is left after they were
hunted down and routed
and julia louis-dreyfus seems to be
playing it with the same kind of rye
humor that gary shanley
played hydra loyal senator stern i would
have killed a bastard too
i mean you would have been doing him a
favor if you've taken out the whole lot
yeah defontaine sounds like she's part
of some shadowy government agency
one without oversight without a public
face which yeah
sounds a lot like what nick fury
initially was doing with shield and
hydra did corrupt shield so it is
plausible that she could be heading up a
secret division of hydra that's still
active somewhere
perpetuated by zola's algorithm which
could mean
empty in my zola hand car could still
arrive at the station
but i don't know it seems like marvel
just pulled a longtime lesser known
comics operative and plans to do
something entirely new with her so it's
not about her history it's about the
plan
you did the right thing
taking the serum of course i know about
that it has made you
very very valuable to certain people hmm
which certain people well notice that
indigo streak in her hair
i think defontaine could be at least
partly inspired by
high-ranking shield agent victoria hand
in the comics
deputy director of the thunderbolts
initiative during the dark reign
now victoria hand already appeared in
agents of shield which kevin feige has
been kinda indicating ain't really mcu
cannon
but since we already saw that character
in a marvel tv show maybe they're
pulling a different female shield
operative from marvel comics either way
it's not just the hair it's the fact
that she
values walker because he took the serum
and she knows government secrets
and the dorm allah are taking zemo to
the raft
prison remember that that was a facility
from captain america civil war
overseen by thaddeus ross whose name
appears in the end credits of the show
associated with
the enhanced humans act and we know from
the first hulk film
that ross was deeply interested in
rebooting the super soldier program
defontaine could work for ross
recruiting super anti-heroes
on a team named after thaddeus
thunderbolt ross the thunderbolts the
anti-hero team
in the comics initially headed up by
zemo i just won't be surprised if this
season ends with zemo on the raft maybe
john walker in the cell next to him as
defontaine strolls past them offering
them a chance for redemption through the
thunderbolts initiative where they can
join forces with other forgotten marvel
villains like ghost like agatha harkness
don't tell me you don't want to see
julie louie dreyfuss and catherine hahn
in a scene together hey look folks i
know you to look at this dumb base in
between all the easter eggs and theories
which can be a little awkward especially
since i'm not really a skin care
aficionado i kind of associate that
stuff with american psycho or the people
that own bare skin rugs
that said i know i should take care of
my skin i am on camera every day which
is why it's so great that the folks at
geology have hooked me up with some
skincare products that i have been
loving
you take a 30 second quiz and they send
you a product set formulated for your
specific needs whether that's
controlling
acne or reducing puffiness under your
eyes or reducing fine lines and wrinkles
they send you a 30-day trial set that's
really easy to incorporate into your
routine
a minute in the morning and a minute at
night before bed is really all you have
to do
here's what they sent me i got this
everyday face wash you know it's just
kind of the basic thing
it's a face wash that you use every day
and then you have a vital morning face
cream you just kind of apply it early on
and all day you're feeling fresh and
then a repairing night cream so if you
spend a whole day building up some
stress acne for getting your theories
wrong
just put this stuff on and then you'll
sleep it all away and i also got some
nourishing eye cream
you just put it around here and uh makes
you look less sullen
and if you like the results after those
30 days continue on with their 90 days
of supplies or order a la carte do
whatever's working for you
they have great customer service and
over 3 thousand five star customer
reviews
people are going to notice the
improvements in your skin i'll take a
compliment over my eyes looking less
tired over a bear skin rug any day of
the week head to geology.com and take
their free skincare quiz to save up to
off on your 30 days trial or just click
on the link below that's geology.com to
save 40
off your 30 day trial so zemo visits the
sokovian memorial that he mentioned in
episode three this is one honoring the
victims of the battle of sokovia and age
of ultron which includes zemo's family
actually that lake behind it looks like
one formed by the runoff from the
upended terrain as the city was lifted
and zemo's music from civil war returns
here
[Music]
oh actually by the way we have a new
zemo inspired shirt design in our merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com that looks
amazing very cool design and you can get
your hands on it again new
accessmerch.com
now this statue has a large sokovian
eagle on it
with a base showing russian letters that
last word translates to sokovia i think
now interestingly
in the december trailer this shot
included a ton of flowers notes and
flags at the base of the statue
and was not yet surrounded by a wall of
names or have a paved surface
i get those other changes but why remove
the flowers well perhaps the flowers
were laid for more recent sokovian
victims of
a global pandemic and whatever that
removed virus subplot was
now they would have changed that before
december but maybe they didn't get
around to updating
this shot in particular yet now bucky
holds himself to rule number two by not
harming zemo handing him over to the
dora milaje
we will take him to the raft where he
will live out his days
and i like how they come and go in that
wakandan talon fighter that we saw in
black panther so sam revisits eli
bradley
future young avenger patriot and his
grandfather isaiah bradley he carries
the shield once more in that art case
that steve had it in
and and gave a nod to his sketching
hobby isaiah cites the
red tails the famous 332 referring to
the 332nd
tuskegee airmen who fought in world war
ii but as the scene goes on
it is a heartbreaking and challenging
scene in which he shares more about his
own
tragic history a handful of us got
shot up with different versions of that
sorrow they tell us
it's tetanus so this episode gets its
title
truth from the comic series truth red
white and black which
explores isaiah's bradley's erased
history as the black captain america and
with this tetanus line
sounds like this show is referencing the
horrific tuskegee experiments in which
the government promised black sipless
patients free healthcare but actually
just gave them placebos and let them die
isaiah goes on to talk about his
missions during world war ii
a couple of the boys get captured on a
mission
i heard the brass talking about
blowing the p.o.w camp to hell to hide
the evidence
and i brought them boys back yeah think
about it this mirrors steve rogers
rescue mission in that first cap film
when he freed hundreds of pows that were
written off as dead pretty much
but instead of the heroic greeting that
steve got isaiah was freaking tortured
and imprisoned for 30 years
isaiah talks about his eventual escape
there was a nurse
she took pity on me wrote up some fake
reports
something she had me declared dead
actually we might have seen that fake
death report for isaiah bradley in the
end credit sequence
so sam goes back to louisiana he helps
fix the family boat with some help from
bucky who brings new gear designed by
the wakandans and we only get a tiny
glimpse as sam opens it at the end of
the episode kinda kept a mystery pulp
fiction style
i'm guessing we're gonna see new
vibranium wings and a color scheme and
functionality that incorporate the
shield
so that sam can feel comfortable
carrying it without feeling like he has
to live up to cap
in fact i think that could be the deeper
meaning of this line why didn't you use
the metal arm
well i don't always think of it
immediately i'm
right handed yeah the way bucky doesn't
have to think about his
arm sam doesn't want to have to think
about carrying the shield so sharon
carter gives a call to batchrock
oh please if it weren't for me it'd
still be riding away in that algerian
prison
i can give you double this time now mt
speaks a bit of french was able to
translate batroc's rant as saying that
he
lost his team on the last mission and
that he would never work for sharon
again hey thanks mt
but this confirms that batroc's mission
in episode 1 was in fact orchestrated by
sharon carter and her criminal operation
in madrapore now again i would be
surprised
if sharon is revealed to be the power
broker herself not just because of the
pronouns but because zemo knew the power
broker before he was imprisoned in civil
war
before sharon broke bad and really
sharon seems like too much of a foot
soldier for a godlike crime boss with
spooky murals
still i do think she is part of a
criminal organization
maybe working for the power broker maybe
trying to undermine him and maybe she's
sending that truck in to help the flag
smashers in their mission against the
grc so that bat truck can gain their
trust and then lure them back to sharon
and the power broker but check out this
painting in her art collection this is
the raft of the medusa it's a french
romantic painting depicting the infamous
wreckage of the french naval frigate the
medusa
i don't know leave that to empty to get
that right this is a real ship in
history i ran aground and then had a
super
incompetent captain that led the crew to
starve and get super dehydrated and
start eating each other so with all the
focus on it here maybe sharon actually
has plans to stage a mutiny on her crime
boss
the power broker seeing him as a failure
to run a tight ship in magipore
so bucky wakes up to see aj and cass
playing with the shield i love that
bucky now sleeps on the couch
instead of on the floor definitely a
sign of improvement and they play some
catch
feels weird sam is calling back his
words to steve when he first picked up
the shield and end game
how does it feel
[Music]
like it's someone else's now notice when
sam catches the shield he braces and
recoils with its momentum whereas bucky
just kind of catches it with a little
recoil
not only is bucky stronger with his arm
in the serum but this shield is also an
awkward fit for sam still with a heavier
historical weight based off of the dark
truths that isaiah bradley left him with
but then bucky reveals when steve told
me what he was planning i don't think
either of us really understood what it
felt like for
the black man to be handed the shield
yeah this confirms that bucky and steve
did talk
over that shield succession off-screen
during end game but also interestingly
that old cap remembered that plan
throughout his entire alternate life
before rejoining them bucky brings back
up steve's notebook and sam
says but steve is gone and this might be
a surprise but
it doesn't matter what steve thought so
does gone mean
dead retired return to another timeline
or on the moon like tories thinks
i mean just show us the freaking
headstone for the old man and leave the
door open to younger cap in the
multiverse and we'll be done with it
sam tells bucky that he has to be of
service to his victims that's a true way
to make amends
probably setting up bucky to return to
old mr nakajima and telling the truth
about his son
next episode and then sam's looking hot
as he's working out with that shield
all day could be a reference to cap's
catchphrase i could do this
all day and his nephew's calling him
uncle sam again
reflects sam's growing comfort with
burying these patriotic colors
meanwhile the flagsmashers grow their
forces in tompkins square park in new
york
somehow getting into the us despite
being highly sought after terrorists
whatever
batroc hooks them up with some weaponry
and their new recruits disrupt a meeting
with the grc who are trying to vote on
the patch act which was told to us in a
news report on w-h-i-h
and presumably it'll be here in new york
that all these warring parties will meet
including sharon carter whom we see in
promo footage and john walker with his
new homemade shield
he actually hammers that together in
this episode's post-credits scene
now actually another big mcu title ends
the same way with credit says just go to
black and you hear the clanging
of a hammer avengers end game
these were of course a nod to tony stark
cameron in the cave weatherbox was craps
in the first iron man
in this scene is a reference to that as
well in walker's man cave now here
walker melts down the congressional
medal of honor that we actually saw him
holding this
earlier and he uses this to fuse
together the metal of the shield now
while i doubt this shield is made of
vibranium or anything stronger
by being made of the military medals it
does bear a deeper more personal
significance for walker we heard him
repeat throughout this episode
i am captain america
i am captain america and this man's
gonna be captain america in his own mind
even if he has to cosplay to do it but
my favorite detail of this final shot is
once again hidden
in his hands as he spray paints that
metal ring he coats his thumb in a
dark red not at all caring about the
blood red stains that he gets
on his hands and yes this is our anarchy
assembled shirt
also available at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube for breakdowns of everything
marvel
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you